en este vídeo te quiero platicar acerca
de las curvas de indiferencia déjame lo
escribo por aquí arriba curvas curvas de
indiferencia
bueno la idea es que antes nos
preocupábamos por unas ciertas
combinaciones de compra de objetos que
maximiza va en la utilidad ahorita nada
más nos vamos a preocupar pues por
ciertas combinaciones que nos dan igual
entre sí sí o sea que nos da lo mismo
tener una combinación que otra para ver
esto vamos a hacer una gráfica déjame
poner unos ejes por acá un eje vertical
y un eje horizontal y que vamos a
graficar aquí bueno pues una vez más
vamos a suponer que nuestra economía es
muy sencilla y que únicamente tenemos
dos bienes si otra vez esto es para que
podamos graficar esto en dos dimensiones
usualmente la economía es más complicada
con tres bienes tendríamos una gráfica
en tres dimensiones con cuatro bienes o
más ya tendríamos cosas un poco más
abstractas pero ahorita vamos a seguir
pensando que tenemos chocolate y fruta
de esta forma aquí voy a poner la
cantidad de chocolate que va a estar en
barras que voy a poner aquí barras
y de este lado voy a poner la cantidad
de fruta que va a estar en kilos lo voy
a poner kilos si aquí van a ser 20
barras de chocolate aquí van a ser 10
por aquí están 15 y 5 y de modo similar
10 20 por aquí hay 20 kilos de fruta 10
kilos que está 15 y aquí está 5 más o
menos verdad está un poquito voy a poner
este un poco más a la derecha
algo así ok entonces supongamos que
ahorita yo yo yo con mi en mi consumo
personal consumo lo siguiente consumo 15
barras de chocolate 15 barras de
chocolate y 5 kilos de fruta 5 kilos de
fruta y entonces alguien llega y me dice
oye sabes que cómo te sentirías si te
cambiamos la dieta si en vez de consumir
esto que consumes ahorita ahora
consumiera digamos 10 barras de
chocolate y 7 kilos de fruta 7 kilos de
fruta entonces yo digo pues la verdad me
da igual o sea me da lo mismo tener esto
que esto me son indiferentes estas dos
opciones como se verían aquí en la
gráfica pues a ver son son 5 kilos de
fruta y 15 barras de chocolate algo más
o menos por acá verdad y luego son 7
kilos de fruta y 10 barras de chocolate
7 es más o menos por aquí y este es por
acá algo de este estilo verdad vale
entonces estos dos puntos me son
indiferentes entre sí otra forma de
decirlo es que están en la misma curva
de indiferencia o bien que me dan la
misma utilidad
total entonces lo que vamos a hacer
ahorita es dibujar la curva de
indiferencia de todas las combinaciones
que me dan igual la voy a poner con este
color rosa de acá a ver si me queda más
o menos derechista es algo más o menos
de este estilo baja así pasa por estos
dos puntos es la curva de indiferencia
que tiene a esos dos puntos y luego
viene más o menos más o menos así algo
de este estilo y aquí arriba algo de
este estilo voy a volver a pintar los
puntos es el 5 15 5 15 y el 7 10 y el 7
10 ok entonces esta curva de acá se le
conoce como la curva de indiferencia así
cualquier punto en esta curva me es
indiferente
por ejemplo igual como me da me da lo
mismo 5 kilos de fruta y 15 barras de
chocolate de la misma manera me da igual
que como 20 kilos de fruta y más o menos
4 barras de chocolate entonces todos los
puntos de acá se dice que están en la
misma curva de indiferencia le voy a
poner por acá
que esta es la curva curva de
indiferencia indiferencia si o sea
elegir una opción aquí no me haría más
feliz ni más triste que estas opciones
que ya tengo va por eso se llama la
curva de indiferencia qué sucede con los
puntos que están por debajo de la curva
de indiferencia digamos este de acá con
un punto por aquí pues este punto la
verdad yo no lo prefiero verdad este
este punto de acá pues no no es tan
buena opción porque hay una mejor opción
para mí digamos y aquí son cinco kilos
de fruta y tengo una cierta cantidad de
barras de chocolate que parece que son
como cinco también entonces hay un mejor
punto verdad hay un punto sobre esa
curva de indiferencia que es mejor que
esté porque tengo más chocolate claro
asumiendo que la utilidad marginal del
chocolate es positiva pero vamos a
suponer esto ok entonces estos puntos de
acá se le conocen como los puntos no
preferidos no preferidos
queridos sí es decir a toda esta región
de acá todos los puntos que están por
debajo de la curva son no preferidos
porque hay mejores opciones y de manera
similar los puntos que están sobre la
curva son mejores que los de la curva de
indiferencia porque digamos si estoy por
aquí verdad si tengo más o menos como 13
kilos de fruta y una cierta cantidad de
barras de chocolate que son como como 6
entonces este punto de acá arriba es
mejor porque también tiene la misma
cantidad de fruta pero ahora tiene más
chocolate tiene como como 15 como 15
barras de chocolate entonces este punto
es preferido sí o sea lo prefiero
preferido lo prefiero sobre cualquier
punto que está en la curva de
indiferencia entonces de hecho toda esta
región de acá la región que está sobre
la curva de indiferencia es la región de
los puntos preferidos bueno esta es una
cosa que te quería contar pero hay otra
cosa que te quiero contar que tiene que
ver con la pendiente de la curva de
indiferencia bueno hay que ser un poco
más específico es verdad déjame dibujar
acá
acá a la derecha una recta para
acordarnos de nuestras clases de cálculo
si tenemos una recta cualquiera de
álgebra verdad no necesariamente de
cálculo pero si tenemos una recta
cualquiera si podemos hablar de su
pendiente de la pendiente pendiente y la
pendiente básicamente es cuánto
cambiamos en g una vez que cambiamos en
x bueno cuando cambiamos en x una unidad
nada más verdad entonces y aquí esto es
una unidad que tanto cambia y déjame
pintarlo un poco más claro hay un
triangulito que nos da un poco más de
información entonces sí este es un
cambio de 1 en x la pendiente justo es
cuánto cambia y si cuánto cambia y aquí
es cuando cambia x bueno da lo mismo si
aquí le ponemos un cambio de 1 o un
cambio de x siempre y cuando tenemos el
cambio respectivo de g y por esta razón
la pendiente es igual al cambio de y
entre el cambio de xy es cuánto te
cuánto se mueve en la variable y cuánto
se mueve en la variable vertical cuando
cambiamos la variable horizontal
entonces aquí tenemos una recta y esto
es la pendiente pero aquí es una curva o
sea no es una recta de este modo si
queremos hablar de la pendiente en este
dibujo de acá no podemos hablar de la
pendiente de la curva sino de la
pendiente a tangentes a la curva vale
entonces pues eso es lo que vamos a
hacer ahorita vamos a hablar de la
pendiente de esta curva en un en un
cierto punto pero con esto nos referimos
a la pendiente de la tangente entonces
aquí más o menos la tangente iría como
algo así verdad déjame
déjame pintarla voy a agarrar esta
herramienta de línea sería más o menos
como de este estilo algo así entonces
ahí tenemos una recta y cuál es la
pendiente de esta recta a pues justo es
cuánto se mueve y pues es sobre esta
recta la variable ya que cuando nos
movemos en la variable x entonces qué
quería decir esto por ejemplo estoy acá
este cambio es más o menos como 1 pues
aquí es como 4 y aquí es como como 7
entonces estos son más o menos 33 kilos
de fruta y acá cuando tenemos digamos
esto ya que es como como 9 y este de acá
es como 15 entonces esto ya que es como
6 va entonces que tenemos aquí tenemos
un cambio en kilos por un cambio de
barras de chocolate entonces básicamente
la pendiente en ese punto nos dice le
voy a poner aquí aquí la pendiente
la pendiente nos dice por tres por tres
kilos de fruta tres kilos de fruta voy a
poner nada más tres acá
cuántas barras de chocolate estamos
dispuestos a dar o sea cuántas barras
estamos dispuestos a dar para que
sigamos teniendo pues la misma utilidad
según nuestras preferencias van entonces
básicamente la pendiente que voy a poner
aquí la pendiente
es el cambio de barras que estamos
dispuesto a dar en cambio de barras de
chocolate a cambio de cierta cantidad de
kilos kilos en este caso para este punto
de acá verdad en este instante estamos
dispuestos a dar cuanto dijimos que baja
seis barras de chocolate vamos a dar
seis barras de chocolate a cambio de
tres kilos de fruta y entonces la
pendiente es menudo social por cada kilo
de fruta que recibimos estamos
dispuestos a dar dos barras de chocolate
bueno pero hay que tener cuidado o sea
esto de la pendiente depende del punto
en el que estamos y entonces qué
sucedería si ahora estamos más por acá
algo de este estilo
entonces la recta ya no se vería así
ahora se vería más o menos como algo de
este estilo
o algo así y aquí qué sucede qué sucede
otra vez si queremos cambiar la cantidad
de barras de chocolate o de kilos por
ejemplo qué sucede si queremos pasar
aquí sería como 17 kilos más o menos
como de 17 a 20 kilos si estos son 3 y
aquí sería más o menos como debe pero
vamos vamos a ponerle que es de 3 a 4
chocolates y de 3 a 4 chocolates y aquí
desde 17 a 20 entonces ahora nuestro
triangulito aquí de altura tiene 1 y
aquí tiene 3 entonces para ese nuevo
punto la pendiente la pendiente es igual
a cuántas barras de chocolate pues una
estamos dispuesto a dar una barra de
chocolate por cada tres kilos de fruta
es decir menos un tercio
lo cual tiene sentido verdad mira arriba
estábamos dispuestos a dar más barras de
chocolate por cada kilo de fruta que
aquí abajo aquí estamos dispuestos a dar
dos y aquí estamos dispuestos a dar sólo
un tercio de barra de chocolate por kilo
y eso tiene mucho sentido porque acá
abajo tenemos poquito chocolate entonces
pues va a ser muy difícil deshacernos de
ese chocolate porque a lo mejor
realmente queremos nuestro chocolate acá
tenemos mucho chocolate y estamos ya tan
en chocolatadas que se nos hace muy
fácil cambiar chocolate por fruta y
entonces eso de ahí más o menos la idea
ya este número de acá se le conoce con
un nombre muy específico a este número
que es la la pendiente instantánea en un
cierto punto de la curva de indiferencia
a este menos 2 oa este menos un tercio
se le conoce como la tasa marginal de
sustitución la tasa marginal
marginal de sustitución sustitución si
es un nombre como que es muy sofisticado
verdad tasa marginal de su sustitución
pero una vez más nombre complicado idea
sencilla simplemente es cuando estás
dispuesto a dar por cada cosa del eje
vertical a cambio de algo en el eje
horizontal va pero recuerde es algo
instantáneo cambia conforme nos vamos
moviendo sobre la curva de indiferencia
entonces aquí tenemos una cierta tasa
marginal de sustitución pero conforme
tenemos más o menos de este bien y de
este bien entonces cambia esa tasa
marginal de sustitución es decir cambia
la pendiente a la tangente de la curva
de indiferencia